you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens greetings and salutations
welcome back to GameSpot's every stage
but we're kind of funny kind of there's
a little bit of a mixture here a little
bit of an amalgamation I'm calm warrior
item joined by tim from kind of funny as
well my comrade as well as chris waters
from GameSpot guys thank you for joining
us but the man at the hour of cross
aaron greenberg from mike johnson around
aaron before we get into it many
congratulations on what i thought was an
extremely strong conference yesterday
you guys firing on all cylinders
software hardware first party a third
party so congratulations on that well
thank you you know we do a lot of work
on the show and many months preparing
and then we sort of cross our fingers
and hope everything technically works
every demo every video and then then we
wait and see what folks like you guys
have to say about it so what were you
able to you guys crunched a lot in there
I mean there's two hardware
announcements technically just to get
that I guess the big one out of the way
Scorpio can you tell us anything about
this I mean we know it's coming late
2017 it's going to be the new iteration
of xbox one or Xbox is this exciting
internally are you guys still readily
exciting I mean I've been on xbox since
we launched the original console and it
feels in many ways we're getting back to
like the core of what xbox and the brand
started with was being about power being
about building incredible games that we
love investing in Xbox Live and for me
you know to be able to unveil a new
console is a very special thing you'd
only sort of get to do that you know
once in a few years been able to do two
consoles and one briefing maybe
something we never seen Brian so yeah to
open the briefing with the xbox one s
and then to close it with Scorpio as I
think someone who stork and so I think
we'll look back it's this will be a
really special III for us the response
has been great you know the thinking for
us was I mean maybe a little bit
non-traditional say hey we're lon we're
launching Xbox one ss holiday a lot of
great updates and features here but why
don't we announce project Scorpio now
but we want our developers to be you
know aware and be prepared for what's
coming right hand as we sort of thought
deliberately about what's that next step
change in hardware performance to be
able to bring true 4k games to the
living room to the console it's sort of
that idea and we know that requires
massive upgrade in power and performance
and so that's why we're bringing a
console that can do six teraflops that
can also do high fidelity VR and you
know a lot of those experiences do exist
today on the pc for people that are
spending thousands of dollars on gear
but to bring that to the console market
something we're really excited about and
so we're sharing that now but we know
still quite a bit of work on the games
and experience between now and then oh I
thought the messaging was was super on
point with all that stuff like the whole
conference as a whole I feel like over
the last couple years Microsoft
specifically has gotten really good
about trimming the fat out of the
conference and really just kind of
coming out the paste is just perfect
it's just hit hit hit here's
announcement announcement whose demo his
trailer here's hardware and all this
stuff and I think that you did a really
good job of kind of going through all
that stuff and building the excitement
but I also think the Scorpio thing is
the one more moment was really powerful
because we all I mean we've heard rumors
right there's been leaks there's been
this than that about both the the ass
and the Scorpio but to see Bolton with
this this press conference I think is a
very strong message especially with the
beyond generations thing that you guys
are pushing where it's like look this is
the plan if you're planning on buying an
xbox you can consider all of this stuff
you can get one right now you can get
the S if you want the the slim version a
couple months or if you want to wait you
can get the the more powerful because it
is coming and I think that's a that's a
really good message to put out that yeah
we were really thoughtful about it and
you're right you know we are gamers so
we watch briefings do watch our own
briefing back and we kind of put it
through the lens of what what our fans
and customers want to see and we know
you know it's more show than tell it's
try to be transparent about what we're
doing and so we're really thoughtful
about that so I'm glad that that that
that that resonate we had a lot of news
okay so but i think you know both to be
able to say listen it's not just about
bringing a smaller box but there's
actually going to be benefits for
customers we know a lot of people are
buying 4k tvs today there is a purpose
and a reason why we're doing xbox one
asked to be able to give you know about
4k video streaming to be able to give
support 4k blu-ray which you know people
are spending three four hundred dollars
four hundred dollars plus on 4k blu-ray
players starting a 299 we've got a great
value for you if you're in the market
for that yeah for you get two games HDR
gaming if you've seen games and HDR it
looks incredible and to know a lot of
the new 4k TVs or supporting HDR so
really there's a lot of great
functionality there in a lot of great
benefits but then this gaming goes
you're right you hit on that point which
is it's not about creating a new
generation for us and that's kind of the
history it's about what if we can
actually create a role where there are
no longer console generations whatever
we could actually let you play the games
you already own and give you more value
and allow you to play those across
multiple devices as gamers we know we
don't always just sit on a living room
and play on our console what are we
could save the games in the cloud allow
you to keep playing no matter what
device you're on what if all your
accessories work and you know it's like
that was the vision and where is it
where's dreamed it up and then we're
like well let's go make this happen I
think the accessories thing is a very
under under looked at mention there at
the press conference because it's like
that's huge you know like when even when
you look at like things like phones it's
so frustrating when they change the
accessories you have to buy a whole new
suite of stuff so being able to like
look forward to the future know what's
coming and still be able to use the
things you have is really good yeah that
was really delivered so we know people
are buying games today they're buying
accessories today the new xbox one s for
example has a new controller very very
similar design of existing controller
which we know people love but we had a
blue bluetooth so that for example so as
part of that now that controller I can
go you know to work to school on the
road and it will pair and work with my
Windows 10 PC and those games that i
have in my digital collection now also
will play there are titles as part of
this new xbox plenty or program so
that's the idea it was started as a
vision you've heard Phil Spencer talk a
lot about putting the gamer at the
center of our strategy and it sort of
sounds great to say that but then like
what do we actually do to prove that and
so I think you're seeing a little bit of
the proof of that vision and and that's
if it's a long vision that we're
continuing continuously innovating
continually going to be focused on this
and hopefully people are seeing a bit of
that pay off this year and one of the
things that sort of part of that vision
you know you've talked about people
buying 4k TVs buying these sort of the
next generation of that technology have
you given some thought about how ok you
can tell people that the new xbox
systems are compatible with and thrive
in this environment but then they also
have to have the TV to get it you know
how are you guys sort of thinking about
how do we convince people it's worth it
to go 4k to get
extra HD are processing and stuff like
her well first we still have a lot of
people today that on an xbox 360 tens of
millions that have not upgraded to xbox
one yet so if they were waiting for that
moment in time there's never been a
better time to do that you get a console
that is forty percent smaller the power
brick integrated you want to lay out
horizontal you want to stack it up
vertically you can do that as well so
and then we say listen we know whether
you have a 4k TV or not it's 4k ready
for you so when you do upgrade to that
4k TV it's there it will upscale you're
competent to 4k and whether it's native
or not and then all the 4k video 4k
blu-ray and you have a 4k TV that sports
HDR are you know we're making our games
like Gears of War like Forza like
scalebound support hgr as well so you
get that benefit whether you're ready
for it now or you're investing people
own cost us for years you know you know
that it's future-proof are you rocking
the 4k in your household current line
not 4k yet yeah I'm 4k at work so I'm
sort of like I get the experiences of
workers you know but I'm thinking about
doing it this holiday hmm can you break
down the HDR thing for me like what does
I know what that means in photography
but what exactly does that mean when it
comes to TVs and consoles a lot of
people are like yeah I'm a photographer
I know what it means but in game well
first off we have people that we work
with and I've sat down these days you
guys know Albert Penello on our team he
could talk to you for an hour or not
each jar alone this is my and I talked
to him and I've seen the games as a
comic consumers the way I kind of think
about it so it's high dynamic range the
it will you know your whites your blacks
the colors the vibrancy just looks
better and so for example there's a
scene in Gears of War for where you go
up and look at the moon we've done side
by side with HDR on HDR off you can tell
the shine of the moon the color of the
moon the brightness of the moon looks
significantly better when you have that
HD are on now if you never saw you going
wow this game looks beautiful the moon
looks beautiful but for people that care
and notice there is a level of
difference and so you know it suggests
perhaps going to the internet and
reading more and getting a super deep
dive because you can spend like an hour
going into the benefits of HDR
lot of the new 4k TVs support that and
so we really wanted to offer kind of the
cutting edge of that technology this
holiday and out of great and on a great
price we were we were talking about xbox
one s Jewish oh I mean OH as opposed to
tell ya thank you you shouldn't you
should work on our team well I do have
one this is our new first you might
notice even the box is smaller the
actual packaging I think the team did a
great job with this i will and this will
be my first ever i want to you look kind
of funny unboxing of the xbox one F kind
of funny exclusive here so I'm gonna
open it this way so you guys can see on
the camera kind of see what's going on
here there you go so done this before
this is maca gene you know all the only
kind of free goodies we give you I don't
know there maybe there's face for a
potential packin game center like a
light I'll build this with flexibility
in mind uh and then you know I'll tell
you personally as a game of the thing I
love the most about this is that want to
be really gentle with so this thing is
that you could actually put this in your
laptop pop or messenger bag so you'll
see it's of the team is calling robot
white so it's a it's a unique white you
can see all the ports on the back i'm
showing it to you and I got to realize
yeah we'll probably be a little more
courteous to the viewers at home you get
a sense of all the different ports we
have here on the back here it comes
where we out here where we go in on
ports so hdmi in and out you can see
multiple USBs you got your Ethernet port
some obstacle how r cetera a couple
things that we heard from fans are
really important to them was that they
wanted to be able to do their binding of
their controllers you want to rebind
your controller put that right here on
the front right on the front and also
has the power button which does light up
and then of course with size you can
also stack it if you prefer that so I'll
sit this thing here right now the big
question is is it coming in black it is
coming in robot light robot white yes
okay yeah so we were moving from
from we're going from the darkness to
die we've gone to the light we were on
the dark sighs we're now we've now seen
the light we're moving from the dark
side you know listen we wanted to do
something different make it stand out
I'm a fan of the mat yeah I like the mat
and I and I just think you know they did
the designers who talked a lot about the
molding and that some of the really
unique things they've done that's never
been done before but you can take I mean
this thing gets you know reasonably
portable so pretty incredible it is what
it seems way even smaller than you guys
are saying it is you nicely configured
you in yeah so you remember last year
you brought us the elite controller
which is awesome yes and this year you
brought system maybe next year we get
Scorpio yeah but it is super it's the
only unveil hardware and kind of fun
yeah but appreciate you look deal we
have and then you'll see the new
controller looks very similar yeah but
that's people were wondering if the
controllers included it's included
speaking of controllers I thought one of
the coolest announcements it was
actually the customization of the
controllers are you guys are doing
internally which i think is really a
really remarkably good idea almost so
obvious that i don't know why no one's
doing it well so many people have asked
about it a lot of people are doing a lot
of you know things after market and all
that so we sort of said hey what if we
could let you go to our website go in
and like customize every you know what
about you want to change the color of
the buttons or you want to change the
colors of the d-pad or put your favorite
school team your favorite game like
whatever it may be so you can order
those its Xbox design lab there's eight
million different options and it just
takes six to eight weeks and they ship
it directly to you it's really i think
it's not really quiet yeah i remember we
arrived doesn't definitely a mighty big
sneaker had a big nikeid fan yeah i love
the customization i think that's just
the world we live in and like we've
never been able to offer that for gamers
and so to be able to do that with the
controller yeah there i think it's great
you put your gamertag whatever I gotta
go pre-med I was a little bit you know I
I got a controller I got a controller I
feel fine with this but then I went on
the website and started clicking through
all the colors like you have a really
nice visualization sort of you can go
through every step you can go back and
tweak the sticks the buttons the whole
thing I did that for about 30 minutes
and I had a blast it was like it really
does sort of change that feel of the
controller and make it feel a little bit
more oh pretty exactly nuts I do you can
go in there and cost
don't have to order one right away you
can save it the other nice thing is if
you already have an xbox one and you're
like I don't need the xbox one s you can
still go through the design lab get this
new controller so you want bluetooth you
want the ability to be able to go for
your pc to your console back and forth
go ahead and order a customized one get
the one you want and you get the latest
controller as part of that and the most
important thing is that they have kind
of funny blue that's an option that was
a mandatory I said we're not doing this
that's the kind of funny blue I heard
you threaten to resign if they didn't do
it was gonna butt ugly we was on YouTube
we took it down but yeah Robbie about
that alright so we've talked a lot about
Hardware very important yeah software
you guys showed a lot of games obviously
gears for looks fantastic out uh you
guys revealed dead rising I mean you're
wearing a dead rising gear right now you
guys you're dead rising kicks on and
condensing Hicks on uh so there was
Jordans by the way yeah yeah miss Jordan
gave us strong yeah there was some
confusion all those been cleared up
since then that the way it was pitched
at the conference sound like it wasn't
an exclusive but you guys are publishing
it it is to xbox one and pc exclusive
yeah we're publishing the game you know
just think very similar to kind of the
rage that we did on dead rising 3 you
know we found with previous titles that
we publish that using the e word can be
very controversial with people so i
don't want to mislead you know how the
internet works today we just want to say
listen we're publishing this game we're
excited to help make this game happen in
partnership with Capcom Vancouver but
we're publishing it bringing it to xbox
one and Windows 10 I'm personally really
excited to get back to Willem at how
Frank come back you know I think it is
not a remastered we got some questions
about that too it is a completely
brand-new dead rising it's coming this
holiday so that's one of our one of our
big titles were excited about other big
titles that were bringing from first
party exclusive starting with recore
coming in September that actually be our
first Xbox play anywhere title and
partnership with an influence on and an
armature who folks know the Craters of
metroid prime where dollars forty
dollars yes so the idea there is when it
create a whole new IP want to create
something new
an action-adventure game you know the
nique style games that there have a
history of building great character
think I've even got Mac who's one of the
core bots here and we wanted people we
know when you don't know a franchise you
don't know an IP how do we actually make
it we don't want to have any bearish
people to be able to go and purchase the
game so we decide to do something a
little non-traditional launch it to
forty dollars just again over to live
our own value for our fans on that then
we go later in September right into
forza horizon three which takes us down
unda and you know I mean all the unique
terrain that you get with that you can
also come meet xbox one and Windows 10
Gears of War for probably on their
biggest game of the year yeah i can'twe
new saga I think people have heard rod
fergusson talk a lot about that wouldn't
be not spending a lot of time with the
team at coalition so we're really really
excited about that as well and then you
know not far after that we get into
things like halo wars 2 in February and
then we just keep kind of cranking as we
go through see if these is coming out on
that window scalebound a lot more title
so we think we have you know this is our
biggest games lineup we've ever had over
the next year as a first party we will
publish and release more games and more
exclusive than we ever have so we're
kind of hitting that sweet spot in the
generation where the content is just
coming and coming really strong yeah I
think with recourse specifically you
mention it I think you would explore the
forty dollar price point with rare
replay last year right that was and I
think that you guys it's clever i
thinkin smart to do that at the middle
ground the space between you know like
the twenty-dollar game of the six dollar
game well i think the forty dollar game
is a place and Sony had recently
explained i did it with ratchet but i
think that rare replay was really the
first example since the the so-called
budget game that everyone kind of
disparage back in the day and i think
it's a good place to be so i'm excited
to play recore I as everyone knows in a
few days like my dude so yeah yeah I
think that's what it is a place if we
try to do that we've been in both of
every play and the gears ultimate
edition but you know rear replay being a
brand new game in that case so yeah we
had a lot of success with it the title
did very well for us and we're hoping to
see the same for record cool one another
keep another key point you guys hit on
was some improvements to xbox live yeah
that's sort of i mean you know for the
past decade and a half of xbox that's
always been an ongoing battle for you
guys to push the boundaries of that and
make it a
or more social more accessible more
user-friendly system looking for group
is something I'm particularly excited
about especially you know playing
overwatch I always want to go in there
with some people on my side yeah so and
I think people know the magic of xbox
live just play with your friends having
a group of friends you love to play with
and different friends like the only
different types of games so the two
things really focused on one is bringing
clubs xbox live to be able to create
those groups of friends but then how do
I actually find people have similar
interest and that's the whole idea with
was looking for group and we've seen
other games like destiny and you talk
about benefits are over watch and so we
think it's going to be we're going to be
really popular with a community we have
a massive community obviously on xbox
live and so we're excited to bring those
later this fall and we also announced
xbox arena some of the platform
investments are doing around eSports and
competitive game in evening you've seen
you know things like halo the World
Championships there he's done a lot of
eSports around gears we have some
programs going with four is ok I mean
competitive gaming is now booming and
obviously we're participating that on
our titles but how can we also bring a
lot of that so that it works across the
platform so that tournament operators
and our partners like EA what they
talked about doing with FIFA can also
take advantage of that as well so just
deeper integration I think it's going to
be a good thing and make it easier for
Xbox players with arena is that
something that you is predominantly you
know for tournament operators people who
are sort of in the business of
attracting eSports talent and trying to
sort of broadcast that out or could you
know a game spotter kind of funny say
hey let's get our get our Invitational
going this weekend and rocket League you
know do an organization themselves
within arenas yeah so the vision is
definitely that's what we want to go
we're gonna building you to be able to
create your own tournaments to do all
that but sort of the start of that is
that first we want to be able to build
it because right now what does simplify
that process so but we did halo World
Championships for example we worked with
ESL we worked with MLG we worked with
gfinity depending on which market would
see we had you know four or five
different tournament operators you had
to go to their website so their rules
sign up Ofcom just we didn't meet it
made you know this competitive gaming
experience way too complicated
right from your dashboard sign up track
your tournaments how are you performing
there's a lot of online ladders and
things to kind of go up to the to the
bigger higher stakes rounds and so how
can we build that infrastructure in
integrate in tournament operators allow
our our studios and our third party
partners to participate so that's kind
of where we're starting but we're
obviously going to be building on that
so that everyone can can create their
own tournaments in their own and their
own competitive you know kind of funny I
don't know who's kind of that the king
of the castle within within your crew
here but I have to call it yeah maybe
five default okay you're right answer to
okay fair enough so that the idea Xbox
is always one of my favorite things
during the press conference and again
this year we got c-cup head again yeah a
whole bunch of other stuff is star do
valley running on consoles and then we
got to see we what a weaselly happy few
we happy few all that tough they can
have a gradual that we found and was
gosh i may be my favorite thing is we we
knew a lot build more I didn't have this
game on their radar we do something
really special kind of remind a lot of
us you know back to kind of maybe like
an indie version of like where Bioshock
started back in the day and so they're
bringing that to game preview in July
we're really excited to be working with
compulsion on that we it's a super
innovative title I watching that demo
and like literally was one of the few
demos where he comes in and you're just
like please please please keep going I
want to see what happens to us the
moment that pinata went squish yeah
first time they hit it I was like oh no
that's not really good looks really
those are the guys that did contrast
right the slide that the same team I
don't know exactly what their background
was but I know that the title is being
built so that the levels are
procedurally generated and the the fit
and finish there is actually pretty
tight for a game that's going into into
preview and the gameplay is incredible
yeah I'm getting serious ken Levine
vibes from that game which yes always
good exactly and then of course we have
inside which is coming to Xbox one which
know people are you know really excited
about a lot of a lot of number folks on
our team have actually played through it
and our saying it's so far with one of
their top games of the yeah you guys are
real sort of vague in this sort of
showing during ID at Xbox yeah
release date let's come to this year and
everyone wants to cut bad the brothers
are staying back home from the show this
year to continue work on the game but
it's been great i mean i think we're
seeing is that we have a dodgy programs
getting to a point where you know we
have hundreds of developers we're now
selling millions of millions of those
games on in the store for these you know
largely very small you know kind of
development studios gamers are
responding a lot of great value in these
games so these are really unique style
games and genres and so inside cup had
we happy few just a few examples you
know as or arc as an example to you know
you've seen it's already sold over a
million units on xbox one dot or yes per
game preview and then being able to
announce that's also a title that we're
bringing to Windows 10 as an Xbox
planning where a title we happy few
another example of a play anywhere title
so another just you know being able to
integrate that and all these great into
indie games into some of the same
ecosystem benefits that we're doing on
the first party I think it's gonna be
good for for our fans yeah I think I
think your heritage like especially with
indie games and xbox live i think is
well established so i feel like this is
your space that you guys kind of thrive
in i think that's kind of an understated
part of what xbox has always been about
at least into xbox 360 obviously xbox
the original xbox xbox one one as i like
to call it was uh was a little different
with xbox live obviously pioneering that
my question for you one of the things i
think is fascinating that you guys are
doing in the you competitor is doing it
as well is exploring first party but
using partners um even publishers & a
studios other publishers actually own so
i was actually really fascinated halo
wars 2 and creative assembly which is a
second studio making xbox game a pc game
how do you guys kind of identify a
capcom vancouver the same with that
rising so how do you guys identify these
different partners to work with within
the ecosystem of your coalition's in
your three four threes yeah well i mean
first what we know is that while we own
some great studios have some great
internal teams some of the greatest game
developers in the world want to be
independent they are independent and so
the ability to go out and to work with
them and to hear their pitches and to
talk them about what they could create
for us on our platforms and so it just
base it becomes an extension of our
internal studio talent and so to be able
to go to platinum and have them be able
to make a title
silly bras with scalebound or the work
we did with remedy on quantum break or
even you know titles that aren't that
big what we did with moon Inori you know
and so there's a lot there's a big
opportunity there will continue we see
that it's a really important part of our
first party business where we are
publicly working with those top
developers and publishers and then when
you get to halo for example crave
assembly that was more case of we just
won't make halo wars 2 until we can get
the right develop right and so they were
we know they are you know best in class
so making RTS and we know a lot of fans
or the total war franchise and so be
able to have them now working in the
Halo universe building what they're
doing with Halo Wars 2 i've been playing
it it's it is incredibly fun yeah and
you know we launched the beta this week
so people at home can actually play the
multiplayer beta this week get a taste
of it and then you know we'll have that
game ready for them in February yeah I
always I always found that deal
especially interesting of Microsoft
having you go to another publisher and
they'll be like your developer will make
a game exclusive presently that's so
fascinating I must have been a little
more complicated than usual deal but I
think it's super complex what a lot of
people don't realize shoes even when we
make internal games they'll still be
part there could be a multiplayer map or
certain game motor things where we do
bring in small or other external verbs
to help with some of the it's just the
tonnage of how much needs to get done
soon as you don't see that but we
actually take the whole game and go out
to them yeah maybe it's a little
non-traditional but ultimately we think
it's the right decision because you know
when you're gonna make an RTS in the
Halo universe do we want to do that
internally as a team that specializes in
making FPS is we're going to go give it
to the Masters of making an RTS game and
so to be able to work with them is a
great honor and I think by the way just
shout out to that trailer which I
thought was awesome i love the way it
ended especially with it was it was very
very cool I don't great way to visualize
the drama of an RTS yeah you know yeah
that's all of the commander with the
chaos of what's going on on battle how
do you kind of betray the story we know
that often you know with more of the top
down view you don't see as much of the
action how do you kind of explain the
back and forth and there's kind of the
knowing your enemy this sort of
strategic you know kind of approach to
the game and yeah we worked with blur on
the trailer who's sort of best-in-class
at that nobody does it better these days
we you know when the team said yeah
we've got blur signed up for this we
were kind of watching and get better and
better through all the reviews yeah that
that was probably the most beautiful
trailer yeah we'll have this year but I
hope I'm glad people enjoyed it cool um
I want I mean technically first part now
I guess mo yang with minecraft up here
how poor it is that studio to like what
you guys do now because that game 100
plus 100 million plus copies sold yeah
is extraordinary in an industry where a
triple a game selling 5 million is
considered very very good so minecraft
an incredible franchise you know for us
and I was really fortunate to work with
the team as we went through that
acquisition a couple years ago you know
I think first it is this game that's
like universally popular wait young old
male female you know console gamer pc
gamer mobile gamer and so we've been
really working to continue to bring
updates you know working close to 20
mojang run it's an infinite studio which
is what they're great at we have a
development team that's working in close
partnership them in redmond as well i
think you've seen being able to do
things like add VR bringing that to gear
VR and oculus rift is a great example of
that we brought it to the Nintendo Wii
this year and so be able to work with
them and just the game of franchise
continues to do really well we have the
friendly update right now out as part of
that we're bringing multiplayer with
xbox live now on iOS and Android and
Windows 10 you can now play multiplayer
across devices which you could never do
before it's always what device what
platform are you go system of my play
minecraft on well if you're on Android
or you're on your bc or you're on iOS
you can now all play together and then
with realms you have this sort of you
know you can actually save your worlds
in this safe secure place or you can
share and save your world sir my graph
across all these devices as well so
whether you're playing multiplayer we
want to share world to have someone else
create it come back
and yeah so we're continue innovate
there and we'll be bringing a lot of
those innovations to the console and the
next year as well also well Erin thank
you so much for joining us today give
our very best to the team
congratulations on a great conference I
hope the rest of you will do thank you
guys thank you all right stay tuned to a
game spot or kind of funny or both
doesn't matter we'll see you later